Continuing from where we left off,
is the importing and exporting within Unreal Engine.
So we're going to hop right into the engine here
and take a look at the project first,
and then we are going to play around with importing
and exporting so we can get used to some of these menus.
So let's hop in to the engine.
So after you've opened up your project,
you should see something very similar to this,
in which we have a folder over here
on the left for the animation class.
Now, you will notice it is blank,
but this is where we can work to keep
things organized.
This is where you can import your animations,
as well as any characters that you're going to bring in.
Then over here, if you open this little carrot up,
you will see meshes and a lot of different characters
involved with this.
The one we are going to work with today
is the Stackebot.
So go ahead and click on that.
Then you're going to open your characters folder
and into the bot folder.
You'll notice there's quite a few folders as well,
but the ones we want to concern ourselves with today
is the mesh and the animations folder.
Now for importing, we're going to kind of cheat a little bit
and use an existing mesh and then bring it back.
But we're going to utilize that
through the animations folder.
So let's begin with that.
Now that we're in our folder,
let's go ahead and head towards the animations folder.
Inside, you're going to find
multiple animation sequences for Stackebot,
but I'm going to choose the Abot Walk animation sequence.
I'm not going to open it yet.
All I'm going to do is I'm going to right click on this
and we're going to want to look for asset actions and export.
So let's go ahead and export.
You're going to get a place to,
where do you want to save this?
I'm just going to do it in my downloads
as it'll be a little easier to find.
And then another window is going to pop up.
This is the FBX export options.
Now going over these just briefly,
the only thing you really need to check on
will be down here for the preview mesh.
You want to make sure that that is checked on.
Now mine is saved on by default,
but if you ever notice this is not checked,
it's because you have not reset to default and it's blank.
So what you want to make sure this is checked on.
All the others you can leave on by default,
including the FBX 2013, and there are other versions,
but FBX 2013 seems to work pretty well.
Then you're going to click export
and then you're going to look for it in your downloads.
That was pretty much it.
There it is downloaded right there.
So that's what we want to do.
So now we want to import that.
Now there are multiple ways
that you can import into your folder.
Now I said that we were going to use
this animation class folder to work out of.
So what you want to do is find wherever it was
that you saved and you can do two things.
You can add it by importing,
or you can simply just drag and drop
from wherever you saved it right into the folder.
I kind of prefer this a little bit more
and just because it's a little more efficient for me.
However, as soon as you do that,
you are going to see the FBX import options.
Now this definitely has a lot more settings
than what the previous for exporting.
So let's kind of go over these.
So it does show that it is a skeletal mesh.
The animation has it included.
So what we want to tell to do is yes,
we do want to bring in the skeletal mesh
because it's movable.
We also want to make sure to import the mesh
that comes along with that.
Now the import default is set to geometry
and skinning weights.
We're not going to go too deeply into that,
but there are some other settings
for various types of optimization.
However, this one works really well for our purposes.
Now, if we didn't have a skeleton,
we could assign it in a skeleton
as you see all these multiple ones,
but we're going to leave that as default.
All right.
And just bring as what is.
Now, going down through here
where there's a lot more settings, as you can see,
and I can kind of expand upon that.
Going down through here.
Now the use TO as reference pose,
that's where you want to kind of make sure
that it is in a T pose,
and you're going to use that for the reference.
So if it's in a different type of pose,
you would want to check this on.
It'll correct that for you,
but we can leave that off by default.
Everything else, in fact,
can be left on and off as defaults.
The only thing you want to make sure
you kind of go down through here is the animation.
So if there is an animation,
you'd want to go ahead and import those too.
We're not going to do that in this case.
Instead, we're just going to kind of go through here
and go over it,
but you could import your animations
along with just importing the skeletal mesh.
So let's just say we are going to do that.
Click on import animation.
You're going to notice these are all opened up for you.
Now you can change all sorts of additional settings,
like the frame import range.
So say you want to only import like 10 seconds
of whatever it was,
you could adjust these here.
But again, we're going to leave these as all default,
except for the import animation,
because we do want to bring along that animation
just to show you how the import export series works.
There's quite a few of other settings that, again,
we won't go over because these are more advanced topics.
However, you could even convert the scene.
You could force a front X axis,
because typically it's not the same axis
in other DCC programs.
You could adjust that here.
You could even convert the scene unit.
So let's say, for example,
you were working in meters and not centimeters,
because obviously the default in Unreal
is a one centimeter per unit.
So you might find that the scene unit,
you bring it in and everything's too large or too small.
It could be because of that.
So you can always come back
and re-import it with this setting.
However, like I said,
we're going to leave everything else as default,
including allowing it to create new materials
and just hit import all.
And it doesn't take it too horribly long.
And you're going to see everything
that is attached with it.
It'll bring in some materials.
So you'll notice he's kind of broken.
It doesn't have the materials that he had before.
So you will have to go through back
and reassign those in this case.
But you'll see here, you've got your skeletal mesh,
the animation sequence, as well as a physics asset,
which we'll go over in a little bit
and the skeleton along with the two materials,
one material and one in instance.
So this is what we want to do for simple importing
from your asset as an FBX.
This is what you're going to tend to see
in your typical import.
Another source of animations is on the Epic Games launcher
through the marketplace.
Here you can find a series of animations,
both purchase and free,
that you would be able to add to your project.
Simply download it.
And once it is downloaded,
you'll notice this add to project option.
All you have to do is click that
and add it to the project that you wish to add.
And voila, you have your animation to use.